the increasing incidence of hustle
acquired staphylococcal infection
is prompting nurses and other medical
personnel to re-evaluate procedures
employed in patient care since most
disease producing organisms are
destroyed when proper
septic procedures are used hand washing
is considered the most practical and
consistent defense against the spread of
infection
the following scenes demonstrate an
accepted method requiring 60 to 90
seconds to perform
hand washing should include the forearms
up to the area pointed out by the nurse
using either cake or liquid soap first
lather the hands thoroughly
then rub the dorsal and palmer surfaces
applying approximately 10
friction movements
next interlace the fingers and cleanse
the interdigital spaces
again with 10 friction movements
now soak the forearms and rub each for
10 to 15 seconds
always rinse carefully allowing the
water to flow from forearms toward the
fingertips
after repeating the hand washing
procedure clean the fingernails
a toothpick may be used for this purpose
dry the hands and forearms thoroughly
with a paper towel
then with a dry portion of the towel
turn off the water faucet
to prevent skin irritation complete the
hand washing with an application of a
suitable lotion
or cream
you